do you notice people comparing you to
nipsy a lot yeah
this is what this is the thing when I
make certain songs yeah you can hear it
somewhat but the the difference between
me and nipsy because I love nipsy of
course of course [ __ ] Legend but I'm
saying the difference between me and
Nipsey is like I feel like I got a whole
diverse just area of different sounds
and Pockets I can go to right I got this
but when you're in your [ __ ] I feel like
I hear it yeah and it's not a bad thing
yeah like it doesn't feel like it I'm
not saying that in a negative way but
yeah yeah this guy might [ __ ] around be
the new Nipsey right right in the same
way when Nipsey first came out Snoop
everybody said he was this is just Snoop
Dogg but skinnier and new lighter
lighter yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but I think
like I feel like sometimes when I hear
some of your [ __ ] like you said when you
get in certain pockets and you're really
on your like La [ __ ] I'm like oh yeah I
hear it man oh yeah screaming and
hollering all that [ __ ] I get that all
the time Nipsey they'll be like uh nipsy
from wish Nipsey 2.0 like [ __ ] I'll be
like wishing Ipsy yeah wish be like I'm
like [ __ ] come on bro but yeah I
appreciate that I take it as a
compliment as you should man